foreign
is going to be a little long but I'm
gonna read it anyway I love your q and
A's I really appreciate the opportunity
to hear curious questions from the
gigantic diversity of people you've
helped so thank you for this my question
relates to the 22 immutable laws of
marketing by Al Reese and Jack trout
also thank you for introducing me to
this book in 2016. it has since helped
me build a business with 1.8 million
lifetime sales for making porcelain
coffee mugs okay so this stuff works
guys it does work and I can't take
credit because I learned from the book
as well and have applied it so I'm
simply passing along something that no
doubt was introduced to me by any number
of people all right back to the the
description and the question the problem
is that I handcraft each mug with my
bare hands using porcelain clay and a
pottery wheel I'm living the dream
making a living as an artist and I'm
obsessed with the art of the pottery mug
but it's pretty damn hard and I'm still
working on long-term sustainable profits
I've thought about Outsourcing to China
the porcelain capital of the world
that's fraught with problems so instead
of trying to grow by selling billions of
cheap mugs I've decided to grow my
business by hand crafting mugs worthy of
a higher price I agree with this
approach I think I think you do not want
to be engaged in a race to the bottom
however back to the text that means
creating a sort of luxury brand since
this doesn't exist today we're focusing
on law number one the law of leadership
that says it's better to be first than
it is to be better these mugs are art
but they're not better than the world's
best sculptures and paintings with which
often solve for millions of dollars each
or fancy ass diamond encrusted purses
that sell for tens of thousands of
dollars each but I believe it could be
the first mug to inspire people globally
as a piece of art that you can enjoy
your morning coffee from every day law
number four the law of perception has
been one factor that helped me sell mugs
for 500 to 1 000 per mug nicely done
but the vast majority of customers want
a cheaper mug how would you evaluate
whether or not a luxury mug business is
worth pursuing and if you determined it
was worth pursuing what would you do to
grow all right
let's hop into this
so there are a few books I would
recommend checking out Joel
as usual I have many book
recommendations so the first which I've
not read in a very very long time but
may be helpful is a book called selling
to the affluent
that's by Thomas Stanley and you may be
able to find a summary and to determine
if it is in any way relevant to you one
way that I assess books oftentimes is
trying to find a Wikipedia page for the
book which will give you a synopsis of
some type so selling to the affluent by
Thomas J Stanley I found certainly
helpful at one point when I was
considering many of the same questions
for different businesses
uh the other book
may sound a little funny at first
because it would seem to be
anti-advice but
it is called
Deluxe subtitle how luxury lost its
luster there's a lot of alliteration
here it's hard for my hard for my tongue
to get out right now but this book is By
Dana Thomas I hope I'm getting a
pronunciation right Deluxe is the name
of the book how luxury lost its luster
and it talks about different high-end
luxury Brands and how some of them have
compromised themselves by Outsourcing
Supply chains and making other poor
strategic decisions but embedded through
the whole story and the various case
studies
is the cocktail of ingredients that have
made some of the most durable luxury
Brands the world has ever seen at least
in the last several centuries so I
really greatly enjoyed this book it's
got 3.9 out of 5 on Goodreads for your
particular case it's about 400 pages
long I think that is worth reading for a
whole host
of reasons and then what I would say is
to your last two questions how would you
evaluate whether or not a luxury mug
businesses were pursuing so I I think
that and I I have this predisposition
too it's very tempting to try to figure
it out right to sit down with pen and
paper look at a few databases and decide
is this worth doing is it not worth
doing
that can be very time consuming it can
also be misleading maybe you have or
actually certainly you'll have partial
information
the question I would reflect back to you
is how could you test in the real world
whether or not this is worth pursuing
right so if you had pick a budget that
you're willing to lose five grand 10
grand how could you use that
to determine to test the waters to see
if people are willing to buy whatever
you have to sell and so what does that
mean luxury mug business right if you're
selling mugs for 500 to 1000 per mug I
don't know what changes in order to make
it a luxury mug business does that mean
five thousand dollars per mug okay fine
ten thousand whatever the number is
there are people out there who will
buy such mugs another question I would
just add to this is what story do these
luxury mug buyers get to tell their
friends
if you look at the Contemporary Art
world you will see I'm not saying this
is the same but I think there are
overlaps the story [ __ ] matters a lot
right you can't just tape a banana to a
wall at Art Basel with duct tape and
have no story there needs to be a story
and there are there are many
documentaries
that you could consider watching the
price of everything
is a documentary about
about Contemporary Art and I found it
very very engaging and there are many
contrasting Styles in here so check it
out here's the description with
unprecedented access to pivotal artists
in the white hot Market surrounding them
the price of everything Dives deep into
the Labyrinth of the Contemporary Art
world that examines the role of Art and
artistic passion in today's money-driven
consumer-based society where everything
can be bought and sold
I really enjoyed this I really really
enjoyed it so this would be another
recommendation because there's there's
again no need to reinvent the wheel I
mean these are not necessarily
identically the people you're going to
be selling to but what does it take to
sell the highest priced X fill in the
blank whatever that is and in fact some
of my answers are going to be
overlapping with
a question from
a listener in Brazil
Carlos I'd like to know your thoughts
about how to Market a product design to
high profile people consultancy for
professional soccer players which
channel would you recommend are there
some case studies to which you'd refer
thank you for everything big fan from
Brazil okay
so all of the books Carlos the soul
apply to you to
all the books and the documentaries I
recommended would apply another thing
that you can do is
study luxury Brands figure out who their
PR firms are go to the pr firm website
and look at their campaign case studies
see what they do right
and you can learn a lot by doing this
and you can create in the old days what
was called a swipe file where you find a
for many years whenever an ad convinced
me to spend money I shouldn't spend so
let's just say you know back when I was
making like you know 35 40 Grand a year
if an ad came across that convinced me
to buy something that was five hundred
dollars that was a lot of money to me
and if it actually convinced me to even
pick up the phone or get online to buy
it whether or not I completed the
purchase I would keep that I would tear
it out of the magazine or I would take a
photograph of it or I would otherwise
try to record it in some fashion let's
say it was a radio advertisement I try
to remember the text to type it out and
I would create a three-ring binder of
all the things that almost or did
convinced me to spend in an inordinate
let's just call it unreasonable
percentage of my after-tax income and
that is another thing that you can start
to do now you do not need to be a
professional Market analyst to do this
you just need to be aware of your own
behavior and what drives you to purchase
decisions or near purchase decisions
so just to reiterate something I just
said
Brands you admire that do a good job
campaigns that are doing a good job or
individuals who are doing a good job
with selling into luxury markets study
what they do figure out who their
publicists are figure out who they're
PR firms are and then study those
publicists and PR firms most of the time
both of those categories are going to be
providing campaign examples and so on
and you may even be able to get on the
phone to have an exploratory
conversation with these people all right
so those are those are a number of
examples